to go along with the return of an adult
animated superhero series we've got a
biop pick about the king of rock and
rolls Queen a biop pick about an
American swimming Legend an adult
animated action show about a Samurai and
a western series about the first black
US Marshall it's all coming up on this
week's what to watch when I was a kid I
always wanted to be my
dad what if that
happens what if I become him and I don't
even know it hitting Prime video for its
second season is the adult animated
series Invincible the main reason to
check out season 2 of this show is that
it's great based on a comic book of the
same name it follows a young man named
Mark Grayson and his transformation into
a superhero as trained by his father
omnimancer defied fresh first season was
a hit with critics and fans another
reason to fly with this one is that
along with bold storytelling is a loaded
voice cast led by Steven Yun sundra o
and JK Simmons with support from people
like Gillian Jacobs Walton doggin
Zachary Quinto and Mark Hamill among
many others what can I say Stars they
love easy voice gigs who wouldn't reason
three to consider Invincible is that the
new season picks up shortly after the
first one ended as Mark is doing his
best to prepare Earth for the inevitable
invasion of an alien race that he is
technically a part of so whose side is
he really on tune in to find
out hi what's your name Priscilla buer
you like Elvis
Presley
of course who doesn't shaking up
theaters this week is the biopic
Priscilla this film executive produced
by Priscilla Presley and based on her
1985 Memoir Elvis and Me follows her
life and relationship with the king of
rock and roll Elvis That's the first
reason to give this one a look another
reason is that it was written directed
and produced by Sophia Copa who along
with being the daughter of a legend is
also an Oscar winner for best original
screenplay for lost and translation she
also became just the third woman ever to
be nominated for best director for that
film she's good that's what we're saying
a third reason to go see the certified
fresh Priscilla is the rising stars that
are leading the way with Jacob elordi
from Euphoria playing Elvis and Kaylee
spany as Priscilla she previously played
the lead in 2020s The Craft Legacy and
has already won a Best Actress award for
her performance in Priscilla at the
Venice Film
Festival Diana n world champion Marathon
swimmer the swim I want to do is 60
hours that's cubit
Florida absolutely not no no no no
that's insane streaming on Netflix this
week is another biopic but this time in
the Sports World with niyad one reason
to dive into this one is that it tells
the story of a world-class Marathon
swimmer Diana niyad who would go on to
become a sports journalist but decided
at age 60 that she wanted to do the
Mount Everest of swims a 110 mile
Journey from Cuba to Florida reason two
includes two big names Annette Benning
as Diana niyad and jod Foster as her
best friend and Coach Bonnie stall n
said the third reason to Splash around
with this one is that it's already
certified fresh on the Tomato Meter with
over 80 reviews and a critics consensus
that calls it an uplifting Sports biopic
with outstanding performances from
Benning and
Foster you have murder in your eyes he
deserves to
Die the samurai I saw its eyes it's not
human another Netflix release this week
is the adult animated action series
bluee Samurai look or should I say
listen no further than the Stellar voice
cast as the first reason to chop it up
with this show with Maya kkin leading
the way best known for starring Hulu's
pen 15 names like Branda song George
teay Randall Park Kenneth BR and mnna
Wen also join in the fun the second
reason to Feast your eyes on Blue ey
Samurai is the story which is set in
17th century Japan and follows a
disguised Master of the sword named Mizu
who is on a quest for Revenge aren't we
all or just me never thirdly the show is
created by husband and wife team Michael
green and Amber no isumi green has
written for shows like small villain
American Gods plus epic films like alien
Covenant Blade Runner 2049 and Logan
with the latter earning him an Oscar Nom
I know I know say
less you a law man or an
outlaw b a mo i Reon another streaming
option this week is the western series
lawmen bass Reeves this Paramount plus
offering considered an offshoot of the
hit series 1883 tells the untold story
of the first black US Marshall bass
Reeves that's the first reason to
consider this the second is a cast that
includes David O Yello as bass plus
Dennis Quaid Barry Pepper Garrett
Hedland Donald Sutherland and Shay
Wingham to name a few the third reason
this one should already be on your radar
is the Taylor sherid in connection the
Yellowstone co-creator and creator of
1883 and 1923 serves as executive
producer for this series and also
directed the first episode everything
the dude touches turns to Gold seems
like it and gold is
good well that's it five picks to
scratch your biopic adult animation and
Western itches they're intense this time
of year be sure to let us and your
fellow viewers know in the comments what
you did check out whether it was on this
list or not remember to check out Ron
tomatoes.com for the latest updates on
scores and reviews for everything
mentioned as well as the movie and TV
World At Large that's all for today
fresh family until next week stay
fresh